hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar post translational modifications
and data independent acquisitions
challenges and opportunities I'm Suzy
Valdez of lab routes and I'll be your
moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab roots and brought to you by cell
signaling technology to learn more about
our sponsor please visit them at wwl
signal comm let's get started before we
begin I want to remind everyone that
this event is interactive we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation if you have any
trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation just click on that support
tab found at the right top corner of
your presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located on the top right of
your presentation window and follow the
process to obtain those credits I will
now introduce today's speakers dr.
Bergen Schilling an assistant professor
at buck Institute for Research on Aging
director of mass spectometry core at
buck Institute an adjunct professor at
USC and dr. Matt Stokes a group leader
at proteomics products and services at
cell signaling technology for complete
biographies of our speakers please visit
the biography tab at the top of your
screen without further ado please begin
your presentation dr. Stokes
and dr. Schilling
everybody thank you for joining us today
this is Matt Seok so I'm going to give a
brief introduction to PTM scan
proteomics and then turn it over to
Berger to talk about her work so when we
talk about PTM scan it's really just the
combination of an antibody enrichment
with liquid chromatography tandem mass
spectrometry to both identify and
quantify post-translationally modified
peptides and really the key to success
in PTM scanner the antibodies that we're
using so typically when we develop an
antibody we use a single peptide or a
piece of a protein or even a full-length
protein as the antigen here we're
showing a phospho peptide the antibodies
that we use for PTM scan however a
little bit different so instead of a
single peptide sequence we actually use
degenerate peptide libraries so here
again we see a phospho peptide it's a
phospho serine residue with an arginine
at minus 3 and every peptide in the
library will have those 2 residues fixed
then we vary the amino acids around it
so we can do this to make phospho motif
antibodies we can also use it to make
antibodies against other PTMs such as a
simulation of lysine so we use these
specialized antibodies in the method and
one of the great things about PTM skin
is it's very flexible as far as input
material so you can use cell lines
tissues we've done plant material
microbial samples whole organisms like
Drosophila sorted cells or sub cellular
fractions even serum or plasma and one
of the first things we do is digest two
peptides so here we're doing peptide
level enrichment snot enrichment of
full-length proteins or protein
complexes
we then enrich with one of those
specialized antibodies take that
enriched material and run it in mass
spect
to get identification of our peptides
and then we can do quantification
looking at what's up and what's down
across the various samples and we're
able to ask a lot of different PTMs
using this method things like
phosphorylation acetylation methylation
other lysine acyl modifications I wanted
to tell a brief story today about two of
these in particular ubiquitination and
simulation so this is just a picture of
a ubiquitinated protein that argot
protein is in the middle in blue and the
ubiquitin is on the left in green and
you can see of attachment of the
ubiquitin to an epsilon a mean of that
lysine residue in the middle of that
target protein when we take and digest
this with trypsin what we end up with is
of course a peptide from that target
protein but any place where we had a
ubiquitination event any of those
lysines we actually end up with a dye
glycine remnant and so we made one of
these ppm antibodies against that dye
glycine hanging off of lysine so you can
take your samples trypsin digest
enriched with that antibody and now look
at thousands of sites of ubiquitination
and samples and we've been doing this
for ubiquitination for many years but we
were never able to do simulation and the
reason is in ubiquitin you have an
arginine next to that dye glycine so
it's cleaved by trypsin but Sumo be it
one two three or four actually doesn't
have that arginine it has three mean
residues so you can't leave it with
trips so ideally what we wanted was an
enzyme that would cleave after threonine
residues but not at arching needs and
that enzyme actually exists so this is
some data from a paper a few years ago
in molecular cellular proteomics where
they were characterizing this enzyme
alpha lytic protease or wall and it cuts
at a variety of residues and importantly
it cuts at threonine residues just after
three needs the other important thing
here is it actually doesn't like to cut
at arginine residues
now we have two different enzymes and we
can take the same sample split it in
half cut half with trypsin to look at
ubiquitination with that dye glycine
remnant antibody take the other half and
digest with the alpha lytic protease and
now look at simulation so a little bit
of sample data on this we took some HeLa
cells and let them untreated or treated
with decimal aces and so these top two
Western blots here with summa 1 or sumo
2/3 antibodies what you can see is when
you treat with those decimal aces the
signal goes down in those blots so we
take these same samples cut with the
alpha lytic protease and run the mass
spec and what we see is basically all of
the peptides are higher in the untreated
sample than in the decimal is treated
alright everything is to the right of
zero in this histogram we can take that
same sample and now block for ubiquitin
just a total ubiquitin block here of
course we don't see any change - plus
those decimal aces and likewise when we
now trips and digest that material and
run the mass spec there's essentially no
change in ubiquitinated peptide
abundance between minus plus treated so
a really nice example of the kind of
specificity of the method and the fact
that you're looking specifically at
simulation when you do this alpha loaded
protease digest so we have this
available as a service and some exciting
new news from us we've actually worked
out production on a large scale of this
enzyme and so we are going to be able to
start selling it as a kit very soon
again want to thank everybody for taking
the time today and now I'm going to pass
the mic over to Birgit to talk about her
work
well thank you Matt yeah so this was
quite a nice introduction infect them
for my talk because I will show you a
little bit data how we are using these
tools that Matt just described and truly
apply them to relevant biological
projects that we are performing here at
the buck Institute for research on Aging
you'll see a picture here so on the
second picture you can see that we were
our master core and our instrumentation
we do have several high resolution
instrumentation for us available and you
know as you can imagine when you have a
core you may have a lot of very
different projects here is like the
short overview of some of the project so
some you know look at breast cancer
others look at more biology concepts of
aging other projects look at bacteria of
biomarkers our Alzheimer's or
Huntington's so you know the the variety
of projects can be very broad but what
is really interesting is that a lot of
projects actually have you know post
translational modifications involved I
mean some people may only want to look
at protein expression but again a lot of
signaling and very dynamic aspects in
the cells can happen via post
translational modifications so we have
and particularly a lot of projects that
are dealing with you know eighty nation
and that may be oscillation or sixth
inhalation or Mullah nation and what is
interesting is that there are are two
peer transferases that at the acyl group
onto a protein and then they're also
deacetylases
that can remove it again and
domestically and you know this always
reminds me this this may be similar to
what you see in phosphorylation where
you have kindnesses and phosphatases so
many projects that we have in fact rely
on enrichment strategies for PDMS as the
PTM levels often are relatively no when
you just look at the light state itself
so we have been working with CSP
antibodies for affinity and
for over a decade already and you know
people even involved in some early
development for a solution together with
dr. Burton and CSP and what is
interesting is that you know Matt
mentioned there are these now new ppm
scan antibodies particularly against
acyl groups here for superior manual and
sub seniors and we have actually used
them and one thing that why we like this
in particular is that they have a really
high enrichment efficiency we often see
between 60 and 80% of them just pure
acyl peptides versus you know other
non-modified peptides so that has worked
out quite well fast and I would you know
and actually never have shown you
there's a suite of phosphorylation
antibodies also available actually here
a paper from net but I wanted to show
you some of our own work that we have
done over the years and you know
particularly looking at a situation here
so I mentioned to you and there are ways
how to add on an acyl group and also to
take it off so these little aces
actually they remove the acetylation
group and when you knock out the B our
satellites you can enrich or you know
you can kind of increase the level of
assassination and then maybe when you
compare that against you know say if you
have a so - and three that's the B are
certain aids knockout and if you compare
that against the wild-type you can see
which particular sites the sirtuin
actually regulates versus which sites
are already there in the wild-type and
are not regulated by the sirtuin so here
you can see one of our typical workflows
we you know digest we take cells isolate
mitochondria we digest the proteins and
then do the other peer enrichment with
the PDMS can antibodies here and then do
it
yes and look at you know either
do ms1 filtering or more recently
researched over to doing data
independent acquisition dia or swath
which is actually quite comprehensive
and in also the combination of these
really very efficient enriching
antibodies with you know modern mass
spec scan types I think that has allowed
us to get deep insights into the biology
of these systems here the role of su
Tunes in this case for example one thing
that is actually very interesting we
find is that you know there's a very
dynamic behavior of acetylation or PDMS
in general on the left and as well on
the right also you can see that if you
take say one protein on the Left
isocitrate dehydrogenase and then
monitor different association sites here
indicated by a different color curves
and and on the x-axis you see say a time
frame like a time course you can see the
very different dynamic response of PDMS
even within one protein so you have to
really kind of treat each acetylation
site as its own because you can see some
they start out slowly and over you know
at two hours have increased a little bit
you know and when you have different
conditions for example of glucose
supplements here versus control where
you don't have that supplement and you
know so you can see some increase slowly
and others kind of skyrocket and have
very high for changes tempo changes so
it's really important looking at the
individual acetylation sites which is a
very different much better versus if you
look at protein expression changes but I
wanted to show you a couple of different
examples and let's refer to this earlier
these antibodies they work on Mouse they
work in bacteria and actually here I
wanted to show you one slide that we you
know we work a lot on
in a situation and bacterial background
and it's actually interesting because in
bacteria you have different mechanisms
there's a satiric away and there's also
something called a superior phosphate
which actually doesn't exist in higher
organisms and members but what is
interesting is that you know you can
achieve a situation through our
traditional way of having an acetyl
transferase they call it here a pub or
cap lysine SPO trans rate you know where
you have the other two strands race and
the deacetylase and you use a superior
Co a to transfer the acity room but in
bacteria there's also the upper tier
phosphate which can do chemical
acetylation so that does not need an
enzyme to do this articulation and so
you have multiple mechanisms happening
in parallel and at the same time so
great grounds for regulation of the
bacteria and so you know one project was
we wanted to find and identify you as a
tier transferases
and you know I mean you can look at the
genome of same e.coli organism and
predict which proteins may be at the
tier transferases
but then it has become you can then over
express them and see if they regulate
our situation but there was a lot of
background in bacteria so we actually
tried to you know knock out a lot of
these kind of mechanisms as I go back to
the last slide that generate our
superior phosphate we can knock out the
copy for example and other other kind of
aspects that are part of the machinery
so we're really looking only at the pure
SPS France race candidates so my
collaborator would make these knockout
strains we call them the guttered
strains that have very low level
wild-type acetylation levels you know
particularly not having the
to frustrate mechanism there and then
you can try and overexpress these
potential cuts so they made 22 strains
and we would in fact you know monitor
all these strains first with antibodies
vest on antibodies and these are
actually also cell signaling kind of
antibodies that are made more for vest
on blotting
so you can see that if it over expresses
like a potential cut and in the vest
anteus appear based on blood you don't
see a signal that's not really an
interesting target for doing mass
spectrometry on it afterwards what was
nice this was a known as a serum trace
and you can see all that has like a
really nice you know a situation pattern
over you know say you're just your
vector you know you're your control
setting here and then you can see there
were some in transferase candidates that
were more promising than others so we
chose those and submitted those for our
mass spec workflows and you know
particularly the ones I'm highlighting
here these we selected and we had like a
set of out of the original 22 we know
selected on five a thirty oh trans race
candidates based on the vest on blood
analysis and we had the what is called
we see the vector control that didn't
have an overexpression of an attitude
trans race we will digest and we
actually would use different n lines
here in the trypsin or glue c but in
separate experiments and then use the
CST PDMS can antibodies to do the
enrichment and then subject to data
independent acquisitions and
quantification so with the data
independent acquisition or swath we can
do identification of the acetylation
sites and parallel and at the same time
as the quantification so that was kind
of a nice throughput we could do on the
mass spec end because we had quite a few
you know
cap targets as well as biological
replicates
number of samples would increase quickly
on the next and then here you can see
you know the swash type data here we
would you know do the quantification
based on fragment ICC or peak areas
plots and you can see for example for
this particular peptide shown here on a
protein called signal recognition
particle protein you know some of these
cup candidates would roll really high
increase in assassination levels and
others not at all
so there's was some exciting specificity
that we could see here but overall you
can see that in these systems we were
able to see many a situation sites that
we could identify in this experiment in
fact over 2500 unique acetylation sites
and actually I'll show you later some
slides if we also digested with other
enzymes other proteases such as glue see
we could actually expand the portfolio
of ppm sites by a multitude here even
going up to 3,000 assassination sites
and the reason for that is that one just
cleaves at different you know chemistry
here at the lysine I mean either you do
trips and lysine ugly or you see out
party acid and glutamic acid so you
cover other areas of the protein what I
show in the Venn diagram is actually
that these surf and cut candidates have
very different site-specific
specificities and the overlap would be
you know there but there are many unique
things that are only targeted by some of
these specific as a few translators this
also is demonstrated in the next slide
where you know you can see you know
where some of the cuts would have
specific targets for some of the
acetylation sites in the give
proteins here other acetylation sites
would be more global and could be
regulated by several of these acyl
transfer ages so this was actually quite
interesting and again I wanted to
emphasize that this project was really
only possible by having a good
enrichment and a nutrition during
Richmond and reproducible enrichment
strategy because we were also working in
the labor free environments everything
has to be really reproducible it was
interesting to see biologically that
many of the central metabolism was
affected here and you know the little
dots show us either in bed or in blue in
the tables allocated which of the cups
had specificity for these sites so this
was biologically rather interesting for
our collaborator and you know you can
imagine many follow-up experiments on a
project like this you can be through
incubations you can look at enzyme
kinetics we actually we have purified
these cups now also on the preparatory
of scales we connected with Shan
McSweeney as the rotation national lab
for crystallization of some of these
cups as well as substrate proteins that
are assimilated so you know
crystallizing isolated proteins but
really releases the mass spec data to
even know which ones are targets which
ones are you know regulated so you know
I hope I can show you in this eco light
project how we used affinity enrichment
together with the dia data independent
acquisition is a very efficient way to
deeply mind the a salome in this
bacterium and the second part I'd love
to show you some data that we did in
light and you know so these antibodies
also worked really well in mice so we
have a superior Co a and
you can now imagine you know you you
know use this a satirical aid either
chemically
acetylate or also use acetyltransferases
in these mammalian systems the systems
we were looking at were actually kind of
interesting well it looks may be now
another image may not know what is
happening here the image doesn't look as
good here not sure why that is the case
but this is supposed to show you like a
liver histology and you know we were
looking at different conditions here in
feeding so maybe I can just rather show
you on the next slide um I'm not totally
sure when I can you see my slides not
sure I'm having a problem seeing the
slide here we must in fact it doesn't
matter too much you know I mean
basically we were having different
acetylation or like feeding regimens and
let's go to the next slide and so
basically we were looking at we were
feeding these mice our situation sook
simulation and then also we're looking
at the asset along the soup sing-alongs
and also as the protein expression
changes so we had sixty two regiments
fructose glucose high set and then
combinations thereof and so and then
five replicates for each of the
conditions so we had overall 60 samples
and so that was quite a large experiment
here so we would process everything with
swaps here and you know that was also
quite nice because we would be
comprehensive in the mass spec nature
Oh
okay you switch to the next slide here
on the next slide you can see our
workflow a little bit and so we would
again you know digest the samples get a
mitochondrial extract and then digest
the mitochondria and then in fact use
the antibodies to enrich here and we
will start with utter till then do it
sucks in urine so basically we would use
two separate samples for that and you
know in fact we would use um you know
the different you know some different
workflows here we call di a umpire to
then analyze our samples
so yeah Empire is actually a module that
was developed by nurse whiskey and he
you know you can basically search dia
data by by themselves so you can
actually make pseudo spectra where you
match up fragment ions to you know your
precursor ions and then kind of
structure together 0 and SMS spectrum
and and then be able to search that in
with you know your typical data you know
search engines
so okay all right so on the next slide
we have developed here a workflow which
we actually call peaked and that is an
automatic processing of these data
independent acquisitions to do data
based searches so you can use the data
dependent acquisitions to do your
searches and then at the same time to
quantification and you know so let me
see on the next slide here just shows
you you know like a little bit of
display how this may look like and in
the end you know when we do this we
would basically get like an entire you
know kind of portfolio of looking at
proteome changes as well as a city level
changes and 16 even changes
one thing that I also had mentioned in
the abstract what is actually really
interesting is when you do have post
translational modifications you can
actually have a post translational
modification maybe on one side or
another site in the same peptide as I am
indicating here here you see an example
where you have enough axial
phosphorylation sites either on the
Sirian 293 or on this fearing 300 and
when you do that depending a collision
you will actually get both spectra and
you know you will get you know say you
can look for distinguishing ions here in
this case the y6 ion and you can
determine based on your mass spec data
whether it was the localization was on
one or the other serine residues so this
is actually quite interesting in has
become something important in our lab
and we have actually developed some
algorithms to differentiate these
isomers and to quantify them
independently by choosing these ions
that are specific for one or the other
isoform so we actually generated some
you know kind of synthetic peptides here
these two peptides that I'm showing here
and mix them in their different ratios
as I'm showing you on the next slide and
then basically try and see if we can get
a linear signal when we measure this
with mass spectrometry and in fact in
this case we actually were able to show
this and demonstrated we met well spike
in different levels of the synthetic
peptides from 1 to 16 to 16 to 1 and we
achieved quite a reasonable
linear curfew so you know that was kind
of important and you know a lot of
effort now goes into really this
differentiating of different isomers and
real-life samples so we're doing a
little bit technology development on
these isomer identifications at the same
time you know we are also combining this
with a new workflow that we have we
we published on and it's kind of funny
recall this like the multiple PTM
affinity enrichment or you know also in
the lab we call it the one pot
enrichment and you know what that means
instead of using just like saying one of
these ppm scan antibodies teh first
Anitha till antibody and Daniel sook
senior Lambert antibody either from
different tissue a starting material or
or from cereal
you know enrichment we were just mix all
the antibodies in in one you know cute
and in one pot insect and you know then
see how you know do the enrichment from
one piece of tissue and enriched at the
same time for our situation and took
simulation one advantage in this is that
if we you're using say you know samples
like Monte Condrey are from mice or
maybe like a kind of the cortex of
Huntington's mouse or the striatum of
Huntington mice so sometimes you
actually rather simple limited in the
starting material so the one pot
enrichment really allows you to start
with you know one set of starting
material and then do all your enrichment
just from that so that has been in the
lab a big advantage but of course it
also cuts instrument time and half and
preparation sample preparation in half
in fact actually I'm showing this to you
here I mean if you do a serial
enrichment where you take the workflow
of you know what comes the leftover of
the acetylation enrichment if you take
that you know it doubles the time or if
you even start from two separate samples
sets you know two separate tissue sets
it also increases the work you know the
work that you have to put in or the
research associate or postdoc in the lab
so but we had to assess well it's the
efficiency the same is you know giving
us the same amount of sizes is giving us
the same quality of data when we
quantify and so we actually
let's hear a little bit so here in this
particular in this correlation slide you
could see well let's see if we do a
one-pot enrichment is that the same
quality versus if we do just like a
single individual enrichment and you
know when or you know we were also
testing these you know you know
sequential enrichments where you take
the world workflow so we have a lot of
different tests and assess really not
only the number of articulation or 16
elation sites that we would obtain but
also the quantitative efficiency and
those and as you can see here we had
actually very good correlations and for
us determined that the quality of data
was just as good as if we do individual
experiment what was actually quite
interesting and you know was that we
actually let me go back to this slide
that the overlap between the different
you know if we the acetylation and sux
emulation sites was sometimes quite
unique and different so you know here
you can see for example is you know we
certainly for the lysine site we had 943
lighting sites that we form both
articulated as well as Suk's innovators
but there were also like a large number
of sites that maybe we only observe and
souk simulated or only observed is
acetylated so that was actually quite
interesting we also assess whether you
know here you can see this actually
shows you for changes in specific
proteins here pH or BT keh or ATP
synthase on the right you can see um you
know kind of the you know lock Q values
your end but also the I mean the Q
values and the lock for changes what was
really interesting in this particular
experiment from the most mitochondria we
actually would see many many
on the complex 5 of the electron
transport chain complexes in rats were
subunits that we saw either suck
simulated or assimilated and really I
think what one advantage of this PTM
crosstalk and one pot enrichment was
that we could see at these you know
different modifications together and not
maybe you know you could imagine that
maybe you lose some 16 relation sites if
you do the individual acetylation
enrichment and you may miss those in the
one-pot approach you would see them
together in fact in the data it was
actually quite interesting we would kept
all these spectra here for example where
we would have mixed species maybe there
was one peptide that we saw both
acidulated as well as sook simulated but
we saw the same peptide also were both
of these lysine residues were 16 lated
so we saw all kinds of really
interesting you know different
portfolios of of isolation sites on one
on the same protein so we can maybe
really try and look at crosstalk of PTM
co and in fact you know here i am
showing you one example where we
actually were able to differentiate
which sites of these Lighting's here
were modified there were two license
right next to each other and we could
actually find differentiating ions that
would be able to see was it 16 related
on one or the other is lighting residues
and in fact we also saw these mixed
species here and then also where was
that scintillation site and verbals the
souq simulation site so using dia and
swath as you are monitoring all fragment
ions at the same time we are able to
extract these differentiating ions and
then do quantification based on those
specific ions and then fact I'm showing
you this here here on the left you can
see you know like a total iron
chromatogram extracted here for
different fragment ions here and the y7
is an iron that differentiates here that
on the left you have the 16 nation site
on that lighting and if you look at the
panel D you actually have a different
peptide species that moves a little bit
later and you get different M over Z
values for these white 7 ions in this
particular case so we would have even
been able to differentiate these
isoforms if they had colluded so this is
really a power of combining you know
really very well done opportunity
enrichment tools and workflows here with
modern skin types and really getting the
most information out of a ppm space as
possible and I mentioned earlier to you
you could actually increase your
coverage in depth even further by using
different proteases we short in this
particular project that when you do
trypsin or digestion or glassy digestion
which more cliffs at this acidic
residues you get a whole different set
of PDM sites shown here either in blue
or red and you know this is the site
level and the same is also true when you
look at the protein level here so for
example oh let me go back to the last
one here so ya see this is the protein
level from here so even on the protein
level you cover new proteins that you
never saw just using trypsin digestion
so when we have when it is important
enough we actually do use this approach
of different proteases so we feel we get
a really deep insight into PTM space and
this was actually true also for this
other project that I showed you earlier
in the e.coli data where we were looking
for cups we use different enzymes here
trypsin n through C and were able to see
a were different set of PDMS that were
not easily detected before and the
reason for that was purely that it
didn't generate well ionizing
right so there are a lot of chemical and
biochemical tools in order to look at
ppm s this is my last slide kind of
summarizing the data so we have really
become interested to look at ppm
isoforms and crosstalk we use this one
pot enrichment in order to cover more
than just one modification at the time
and you know we often now use CI a swot
workflows in combination with
quantification in skyline and
open-source software to get the most out
of our quantification data and also to
be able to easily visually access the
data that we achieve and require from
the instruments so I think what I have
shown you today is a big interest that
we're having and PTM dynamic dynamic
aspects of PTM research and getting as
much depth as you can and the ppm scan
antibodies were a great tool for us and
all these projects and have allowed us
to really find interesting biological
events I like to close with showing you
my group here at the buck Institute in
California and I'd like to thank members
of my group and of course also CST my
other collaborators and you know kind of
our grand support and I like to show you
a written picture from last year from
the buck Institute here and I'd love to
open this for questions and I'll be
happy to answer anything you'd like to
know about our workflows or other
aspects you know kind of experiments
that we do here thank you
and thank you dr. Stokes and dr.
shilling for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have
any questions you'd like to ask please
do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far love
your screen will answer as many of your
questions as we have time for so let's
take a look at our questions our first
question is a two-part question dr.
Schilling and dr. Stokes
are you considering including more post
translational modifications in your
one-pot approach such as ubiquitination
or methylation that's the first part of
the question and it the second part is
is there a limit to the number of
modifications it would be appropriate to
combine okay so maybe I start off with
answering this so yes we definitely have
a high interest in expanding on the
portfolio of one pot enrichment
antibodies or adding other PTMs to it in
fact the ones that was asked about
specifically ubiquitination and
methylation those would actually fit
very well for adding them into the one
pot enrichment the reason being because
the only thing one has to consider is
that the workflow and the you know kind
of solvents and buffer that that works
for all the antibodies that would enrich
the specific PDMS as particularly here
for you recruit ination and methylation
as Matt mentioned earlier CSP antibodies
are also available and they actually use
a very similar set of conditions to
perform the enrichment so that should
actually work very well and we have
actually started with some pilot
experiments doing this so I think this
is actually very interesting adding more
to it the second part of the question
was is a limit to the number well I mean
in theory it shouldn't really have a
limit the one thing that one might
consider
is just the case that maybe at some
point it does the mixtures do not get
too complex because one reason why we do
these enrichments is that you know we
can focus most of our mass spec time on
the enriched PDMS but on the other hand
that is usually not such a problem when
we look at PTM enriched fractions
they're usually really not that complex
and you know with the modern mass
spectrometers they are so fast scanning
and have such good sensitivity that I
see this to be actually be a really
interesting trend for the future
thank you very much and are you
generally able to confidently determine
the site of modification
thank you yes so I mean using these CIA
workflows we found that that has really
improved our ability to identify the
site of modification because you know
you do you know when you people do data
dependent acquisition what often may
happen is that you trigger the ms/ms
spectrum on one isoform and then there's
dynamic exclusion for that particular M
over Z pre cosine if one does use data
independent acquisition everything will
be manat or monitored all the time as
part of you know what the concept of
data independent acquisition is so so
that has helped greatly I will have to
say for the isolation this has worked
actually extremely well it is sometimes
a little bit more challenging for the
phosphorylation as you all know
sometimes there are stretches where
there's multiple shearing or true Union
you know residues right next to each
other then it does get become become
more challenging but but you know in
many cases this actually is possible
thank you in another question coming
from our viewers with the DIA one-pot
method be appropriate for
phosphorylation analysis that is also a
very good question and you know the so
for example what was I thought you know
as a usual very impressive for me was
also to see the portfolio of
phosphorylation enrichment antibodies
that Matt showed earlier in this
presentation you know focusing on
phosphorylation enrichment for different
pathways and you know those serine and
threonine and foot and tyrosine
antibodies so yeah I do think that there
one could also combine these particular
tools we haven't done this for the
phosphorylation yet although I have to
say in the past I mean other groups have
done this kind of work you know
combining cross for enrichment methods
so I actually do think that this is just
equally possible and it might even be
interesting to try and see if one can
combine different classes of PT MCM so I
do think there's a lot of you know space
to explore these things and really look
at these PTM cross talk and you know I
think dynamics in particular
thank you our next question coming in
would you expect similar results using a
data dependent scan type
so I mean I think for you know getting
the very high numbers of PTMs that I
showed in some of my presentation
earlier for that definitely the DBA will
also be I think a very good way in order
to work with I mean having a workflow of
doing the you know enrichment and then
the DBA identification or maybe then a
TMP quantification for you know but what
I was saying for if one really wants to
look more specialized also on the site
localization I do think that maybe the
dia has some advantages over it because
of the comprehensiveness and maybe the
ability not to lose very minor isomers
that may be present so you know I mean
we in our lab we have shifted over a
little bit more tending to the DIA
approaches you know that's just the
preference I guess in our lab right
thank you and I want to thank our live
audience today for their questions we
have time for a couple of more would
this approach work for serum samples or
other sample types yeah I think you know
as what we have actually a lot of
different centers in our Institute we
sometimes also get like you know like
c.elegans samples or to sofala we have
like a broad spectrum I have in the past
worked with a serum or actually rather
plasma and we did do a lot of
glycosylation analysis yeah I do think
you know that this this particular
workflow and the PDM you know one-pot
workflow and these antibodies they
should just refine in plasma in fact
this is something that we are so you
know intending to do with some kind of
longitudinal sensors that we will get
from plasma soon so yeah that should
work just as fine yeah and I'll just
interject here as well I think you know
one of the cool things about doing the
PTM scan in a serum or plasma sample is
what we found in published on is that it
kind of obviates the need for depletion
kits or depletion columns from that
serum so you can directly take that
serum you know problem with serum of the
abundant proteins things like albumin
the other 20 abundant protein um you can
take that sample now and just do say in
a Cell lysine enrichment or methyl
arginine enrichment now you don't have
to do plea before and you're getting a
real good kind of look at even lower
abundance proteins in that serum by
doing the the enrichment
Thank You dr. Stokes and dr. shilling we
have time for one more question from our
viewer if you compare a be enriched
samples versus label-free acquisitions
of non enriched samples do you see
modified peptides that escape the
enrichment due to PTM context not being
optimal for a B detection and if so how
do you deal with such biases
yeah that's a very interesting question
I do think that it's probably true that
one will miss some you know ppm sites I
think any given drug flow will have
certain strengths and maybe you know
some something that one may miss so I
mean we and also you cannot you cannot
exclude but I mean I think the dynamic
range enrichment that one does get
through the affinity enrichment I mean
that is a specific strength that I do
believe you know really contributes to
identifying that many sites we have
actually worked with somebody before Sen
painless his name on some of these
e.coli project and bacterial projects
they have actually done analysis just
out of the regular lysate without
enrichment but you know I mean for us
also what is really important is not
just identifying something but it's
mostly that we want to quantify them and
when we do these enrichments the space
and the matrix is so much cleaner
because you really only say you have 60
to 80% of these PTM enriched peptides
now available so the quantification that
we do afterwards in skyline from the DIA
acquisitions is so clean and has so
little interferences that that is really
important to us because the
quantification of different conditions
that really basin biological interest
however we have actually talked with
some other researchers where we we we
have now built some of our libraries out
of the enrichment strategies and now we
have given our libraries to some of our
colleagues who then use these given
libraries and dia mode and look for
these peptides that we now know are
there out of the entire life State you
know without enrichment so I think
combining these different workflows and
intelligent or smart design of the
experimental you know aspects I mean
that's kind of
you can get a lot of information out of
that and I think there's a certain
strength and having these different
workflows and and just knowing what is
my focus and what do I want
and what's my what's most important to
me yes so I think Burgin is absolutely
right and I would just add to that that
whenever we're preparing one of these
PTM or motif antibodies our goal is
always kind of the broadest coverage
possible or to generate something that
really is context independent and it's
really only dependent upon presence of
that PTM so all of these products are
monoclonal products but what will
actually do is take clones that we get
test them via Eliza or actually test
them in PTM scan and look at the
peptides that we get out of each of
those individual clones and in some
cases combine multiple monoclonal clones
into one product a great example is the
Isetta lysine so that's actually a mix
of seven different monoclonal clones and
we did that to really maximize coverage
and get one reagent one tool that should
in principle be able to pull down any
lysine Isetta lated peptide
dr. Stokes fara shillings thank you for
your presentation today would you like
to provide our viewers with some closing
remarks oh yeah sure so you know I do
really think that it is very interesting
having these developments particularly
using taking advantage of the
specificity of these antibodies and
really using them and applying them to a
biological project and having making a
hypothesis maybe you know okay I do have
some evidence that the PTM space your
changes and you know having this
combination of a smart workflow and
sample preparation that's really highly
reproducible with an interesting
biological question and then as I
mentioned the appropriate mass spec skin
type and I think that really can help
the biology collaborator to get the most
out of their precious biological
material and and gain biological
insights which is really the ultimate
goal of the experiment and from my end I
would just again thank dr. Schilling for
sharing her work today you know CST is a
company of scientists for scientists and
it's really always exciting for us to be
able to see our products be put into
action and doing the kind of
cutting-edge research that she is doing
thank you well thank you both dr. Stokes
dr. Schilling for your time today and
again for your important research we'd
also like to thank lab roots and our
sponsors cell signal technology for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go I want to thank the
audience for joining us today and
further interesting questions questions
we did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via
contact information that you provided at
your time of registration so if this
webcast can be viewed on-demand through
April 2019 lab routes will alert you via
email when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share this email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
until next
I am bye-bye